[Sebastian:] Let me talk about dynamic programming with stochastic actions.
At the end of this assignment, you'll be able to program this.
The motivation to study this is as follows:
suppose we have a robot, and we have an obstacle and a goal state.
Then this robot might be tempted to scratch the wall over here and head towards the goal.
In practice this is a bad idea, because robots that get really close to obstacles are frightening.
In fact, if their actions aren't quite perfect they might actually hit the obstacle, which is no good.
In practice, what we tend to do is we go more like this.
We maintain a certain clearance to obstacles.
Now we're going to modify our dynamic programming planner to do just that--
to find paths that are a little bit safer and lead a little bit away from obstacles.
The way we will do this is we will model actions as stochastic,
and we have not done this before, but you'll learn how to do it.
Take the action of going north from the from the cell over here.
In a deterministic action, it obviously succeeds, unless of course we run into a wall.
In the stochastic case, it succeeds with a certain probability--say 50%--
whereas with 25% chance, it might accidentally go left or right
even though we commanded it to go up.
This is a stochastic action, and it's exactly the type of action I want you to program later on.
If, for example, there was a wall over here and the robot decided to go up,
there'd be a 25% chance it would hit the wall, which is not good.
So staying away from the wall is a good idea in a stochastic situation.
I will now show you how the backup works without asking or quizzes.
Suppose we study the action of going up over here, and we have a 50% of success.
Suppose at the time we do the backup, the value over here is 10,
20 over here, and 40 on the right.
Then the value of the state for the action "go up" would be obtained as follows.
It's a 50% chance times 10, 25% times 20, and 25% chance times 40 plus 1,
which is our motion cost, which together gives me 5 plus 5 plus 10 plus 1 equals 21.
That is the backed up value over here for the action go up,
and you can do the same with go right, go left, go down.
The interesting case in your implementation is the one for an action
that either runs off the grid or into a wall.
Let's study the case of going north from this cell over here
where there is a 25% chance of falling off the grid.
Then the value for the cell and the action of going north
is 50% times 20, which is 10, 25% chance times 40, which is also 10,
and then we have this case where we fall off the wall.
Let's define the penalty for falling off the grid or for hitting an obstacle as 100.
So we add 25% chance times 100 plus 1, 1,
hence the new value is 10 plus 10 plus 25 plus, which is 46.
I want your update to produce for the cell over here 46 for this specific action of going up.
Of course, the value might be smaller because there might be a better action
like the action of going right.
But for this specific calculation you should receive 46.
Your programming assignment looks as follows. I will give you a grid.
In this case it's a grid that's entirely unoccupied.
As before, I give you a goal state and a set of actions.
I want you to program dynamic programming all the way to the end,
so when I run it, the values I get are 0 for the goal state,
37 for the 2 adjacent states, and 44, 16, and 63.
If I go right to the goal, there is a 50% chance of hitting the goal,
in which case my cost is just one, which is the cost of motion.
There is 25% chance of running into the wall,
which costs me 100 plus, of course, 1 for the robot motion,
and there's a 25% chance I find myself down here, which costs us 44.
If I put this into mathematics, we get 50% chance for reaching the goal,
25% for hitting a wall, which costs me 100,
25% for going south, and the value here is 44.77 plus the cost of motion is 1.
If you add this all up, you get exactly the 37.193 that this value over here constitutes.
After conversions for this grid, I want the value function to look just like this.
Here is the corresponding policy.
If I modify the grid to insert an obstacle over here,
then I get a value function like this. One thousand is my initial value for each cell.
It's unmodified for the obstacle cell, and these are the values I receive--
94, 86, 73, and 44.
You can check whether these values are correct.
Let me pick a slightly bigger grid
with a goal position in the top right corner and two obstacles down here--size 4 x 4.
Here is my output for the value function. I can read those values.
They happen to be 1000 for the two obstacles.
What's remarkable is the policy.
When I'm close to the wall, you can see that I'm being pulled away
from those wall elements to stay in free space.
I will eventually reach the goal, but I never am willing to drive in a way
that crashes me into a wall if it's not avoidable.
What you have to do with the code we provide is to modify
the dynamic programming routine that assumes a deterministic action
with the one for a stochastic action.
Specifically, what this routine should do is it should incorporate
the probability of successful action and the collision costs.
For example, if I modify the probability of success into a deterministic function,
then my value function will look as follows.
It's just a number of steps in the usual way--1, 2, 3--as before,
and the policy drives me straight to the goal as shown over here.
In your final submission, please exclude any printouts
so we can modify the grid and these values for success probabiilty and collision cost,
and we can see what your code generates.
In the initial value function, please initialize your value function with 1000.